[Music]
cover crops are an integral part of
sustainable agriculture because of their
role in soil stewardship Pest Management
and crop rotation while many vegetable
farmers in the Northeast use cover crops
typically the practice is limited to
small grains for preventing winter soil
erosion this video features 10
experienced vegetable Farmers from five
states explaining how they use cover
crops in more innovative ways the
farmers describe which species of cover
crops they plant and how they are
managed viewers can decide for
themselves whether a particular practice
is suited for trial on their own Farm
[Music]
I'm Hank Bell we're at Lewis Creek Farm
in starksboro Vermont we have 60 Acres
under cultivation 35 Acres of vegetables
we sell wholesale retail at the farmers
market and Retail at the Farm
Stand I'm a cover crop fanatic anything
that's not in vegetables I want to keep
in a cover crop I think of it as a bit
of a free lunch where there's very
little time or money invested for a lot
of fertility
returned winter Ry is the basic cover
crop that most people use I used to just
grow winter rye and about 10 years ago I
started growing hary vetch in with the
Rye hary vetch is a winter annual it's
planted in the fall puts on a little bit
of growth stays alive through the winter
and then puts on a lot of growth in the
spring much the way Rye does
without
nodulation the vetch wouldn't fix any
nitrogen when I first started growing
vetch I inoculated it every
year I'm much more casual about it now
sometimes I don't inoculate at all this
field was not inoculated last fall and
it does have nodules on it now that I've
grown it all over my farm the inoculant
is resident in the
fields when I plow Ryan Harry vetch down
at this stage for crop sweet corn for
instance I find that I can do without
most of the nitrogen uh normal nitrogen
applications I do put on a starter I put
on about 30 pounds with a starter mix 30
pounds of nitrogen then I keep track of
it with a prid dress nitrogen test to
see if I've got you know if we've got
heavy rains we might lose a lot of it I
find that the amount of nitrogen that uh
Ryan Harry vetch produces will
feed early to
mid uh season varieties of corn
completely so Corn's up to about 5 feet
high when you get into those big late
varieties of corn they seem to be using
enough more nitrogen that it requires an
additional side
dressing this is a field of oats and
vetch what's noticeable is there's no
oats this is the spring the oats have
winterkilled what's good about that is
you don't have that coarse grassy matter
that takes so much time to break
down the major thing I like about oats
and vetch is that when it's plowed it
leaves a lot less stemy trash and makes
a nice fine seed bed it's good for
direct seeding the Ryan vetch is better
for transplanting
yeah C well they always look good
yeah white that
pretty I like to get all the fields
covered with a cover crop but some crops
come off too late in the season to get a
cover crop in the last seating date for
winter Rye is October 15th so for crops
that are harvested after that date you
either have to leave the the field be or
you can intercede them we came in with
buckets of Ry seed each person taking
one row and scattering seed up through
the
row one person could do an acre in 40
minutes I use this technique of
interceding rye on most of the late
season coal crops broccoli cauliflower
cabbage brussels
sprouts this was a field of cauliflower
the rows are closer together than
Brussels sprad outs you have to be a
little bit careful not to get rice seed
into the cauliflower plants you don't
want the Rye to get in the plants
because it'll actually grow in the head
uh just from the moisture of dew
alone this is a field of Brussels
sprouts that was protected through the
winter by winter Rye we got the Rye on
here the first week in September we
cultivated it in and and now we have a
good crop of Rye protecting the field
and something to plow down as well